hans a tough game here against alaresa
perugia do you seem a
bit concerned do you think you missed a
chance of course i missed a chance
it doesn't take a genius to figure that
out dunk us a little bit through some of
these variations you played this great
move queen g3 what were you expecting
from here okay this entire game was just
brilliant for me up until bishop d3
like queen g3 and uh okay let's say king
h8 or he played king of [ __ ] no what if
he takes
page
six okay let's say g6
okay
i don't even need to show variations you
just look at the position yeah like okay
let's say okay only reason bishop g5
isn't working immediately because maybe
f6 works
right f6 so
fine not this year but just f4 like i
don't like simply f4 and then what is
black going to play f4 where instead of
bishop g4 just f4 like what what's
happening okay
my pieces are literally perfect his
pieces are just terrible i have bishop
g5 next
i except to go like h4h5 like
come on it has to be lost
like i don't understand
what universe this is not completely
lost for example let's say king h7
bishop g5 queen eight or d7 27 queen h4
bishop g5 take on d7 queen h4 bishop for
six for example so if k7 doesn't move
then then okay what's the move uh queen
e7
to go to c5 and then what are you going
to do
how there's absolutely zero way like
th this side of the board is cut off
like okay let's say bishop g5 okay you
don't you definitely let's say queen c5
king h2 i can't play f6 here
f6 i guess you take on c4 avengers
so let's say queen c5 okay
king h2 for example uh-huh okay
what are you playing uh
yeah i just did not believe in the
position for black okay i just don't see
any universe where this is uh holdable
really after like bishop d8 or something
like this bishop h6 okay so many moves
it's not like uh
i mean instinctively i'm like okay what
is this there's just no way it's just
zero chance
zero chance zero i just don't believe it
you know okay
uh so he didn't go before that he went
for king hi did you expecting a chain
instead of course
most the move i expect most and after
knight d6
okay knight c5s
okay obviously a bad move
um okay let's let's i can show some
variations there's actually really nice
variation
let's say instead of um
what was it
instead of
uh okay there's g5 let's say instead of
knight c5
g5 here yeah g5 so i thought that either
he goes g5 and tries to do something
concrete or it's just very bad
so here uh even rook even h4 is a move
here
okay and let's say uh take take uh you
have to go king g7
yes and rook d3
and rook h8 is the only move i guess
and here i wasn't sure
um
sure i thought that maybe wasn't enough
um
[Music]
peter's asking about h4 bishop takes d6
first oh yeah this was a this was a
problem here no way yes that's because
you take taken yeah exactly
maybe i was trying to make something
like this work but again uh there was
just bishop e3 simply
ah yes of course bishop e3
and uh here i was like okay this is this
is obviously very bad
yeah before coming and you have a
sacrifice material exactly and uh so he
plays knight c5 which you did not think
it was a good move
yeah rook d4 okay now take take knight
e4 of course it's all correct take take
take again here bishop d3
i missed um
uh let's say bishop five yeah bishop e5
queen g5 rick g4 yeah and i thought i'm
so smart because bishop g4 f4 right
queen h5 hg queen d8 queen g4 jade queen
of five but then here's queen c1 yes
and here i was still king h2
bishop g4 and then oh i thought maybe
bishop takes g7 but he just goes back to
g5 i thought i even considered a four
here i considered
queen g4 but it just wasn't working
uh so then i this was just very
i should have been more uh
disciplined there with my thought
process but but and okay let's say just
instead of bishop d3 let's say bishop e3
yeah bishop b3 in this position just
game over again
basically right like it's just pure
domination yeah it's a very strong
position for what you have the pawn and
the pair of bishops still strong so it
was based on a miscalculation that you
played bishop d3 we had a feeling that
you had missed queen c1 yeah it's
the sort of queen c1 back to g5
it's a weird idea but you know i missed
it
i paid the price
well you still managed to hold on to a
draw did you ever feel that you were in
danger on i wouldn't say hold on
definitely i wasn't the one holding on
uh even after
let's say what did i play rick e3 i
still should have some advantage right
without the bishops we weren't as sure i
definitely don't think i'm ever worse
here so i think holding on would not
here for sure yeah for sure no i was
never in any danger uh
that's for sure i don't think that how
how could i ever be in danger when i
have the d6 pawn
like uh
perhaps i could have been more precise
like
i don't know this this g4 moment maybe
it was a bit hasty
but uh here okay let's say i don't play
g4 let's say play like
okay of course i'm i should have an
advantage here because
let's say i sit and like say i go pish
before okay maybe it's not a huge
advantage but
okay let's say i play c4 for example c4
in this position yeah i think i have a
slight edge
because this is such a passive position
um and then i thought uh
b6
rook b3 rook b8 b3
brick
i wasn't sure how to proceed i thought
maybe bishop before
uh-huh
but that was a bit and you know always i
always had bishop take their six ideas
looming
maybe this was the way to proceed but i
definitely think i have an advantage i
just definitely didn't use it the right
way i'm curious what is the computer
saying
in this position yeah what does it say
i'm just curious uh this position it
gives about zeros okay so pushing can we
go back just like let's say right after
right after rook two to e3
rook to e3 yeah just i'm just curious
okay it's equal well interesting and
bishop b3 what is the evaluation it's
like plus 1.5
oh well let it think a little bit higher
depth it's probably going to be like
plus 2 well
yeah it's okay rick8 then bishop d3
that's also the only move wow yes
yeah okay maybe i shouldn't be that
upset but uh
like i felt like i played the opening
really well
i felt like the play was flowing
uh quite well but just
didn't it's similar with the roni whole
game i feel like i'm out playing and
then
the the killer blow wasn't quite there
right
hans we got to ask you what are the
players feeling uh seeing that magnus
carlsen didn't show up before the game
today yeah actually it really i i was i
was like struggling to even like focus i
was thinking about it the entire game i
was like
i've never ever in my life uh
heard of a top player forfeiting a game
even the world champion
okay i don't know if he said he wasn't
gonna play before or after the game but
for me to like see him forfeit the game
especially the first time in his career
yeah
it's like
like it's just a very very uh
i don't know what's going through your
mind well
i'm speechless to be honest
it's like it's very weird yeah
first he gives up the title which i
thought was first
i
certainly
was surprised and then now this
okay i don't want to draw any
conclusions but it's very strange
but at least i got to beat him before he
left that's that's the good thing
absolutely well i mean you must be happy
with this game and certainly with the
quality of your play in this tournament
so far
well who cares about the quality results
is what people remember so uh
i uh this game against erroneous in here
i think i should have won both of these
games considering um the opening chances
i got and
the mistakes they made but you know
converting is a skill and uh at least i
can play decent chess
you're currently on two points out of
three so your lead has beautiful yeah
you're on two out of three all of magnus
carlsen's uh results will be annulled
and i get the rating right you do get
the radio
really yes oh that's pretty ridiculous
but wow so oh to what okay
yeah
i see
i guess you just didn't want me to win
the tournament so you had to leave you
know yeah
i guess that was the only reason yes you
can't think of anything else
well
hans uh you think that he has some kind
of personal thing against you why did
you mention that no i have no idea it
was just i was it's obviously sarcastic
comment yeah
uh because it's okay like
uh out of the the four games you know
he's like helping napo because he lost
you know
yeah i have no idea
about anything it's just
it's uh
of course i would prefer for the winter
count let's just leave it at that well
it counts for your rating you're still
over 2 700 and you're still putting on
an impressive tournament here at the
sinkhole cup
it's okay it's okay considering my
current rating you guys might think it's
impressive but
i'm always striving for more
okay well hans thanks for joining us
here in the studio certainly we look
forward to the remainder of your games
and good luck in them thank you indeed
hans good luck and thank you for today's
very entertaining game